[A] What is Stellar doing that benefits everyone?
[B] Our primary use case is called real world assets or stablecoins.
[B] And so when you think about crypto,
[B] you know, you think about Bitcoin.
[B] Ethereum.
[B] All these coins that are like going way up in price
[B] or way down in price.
[B] All this volatility.
[B] Almost gambling on price.
[A] Right.
[B] Right?
[B] That's not what Stellar is for.
[B] Stellar is for the really boring stuff.
[B] We just basically want to make money as simple as email.
[B] If you want to send someone an email.
[B] You just type in their address.
[B] Hit send, it's there.
[A] Yeah.
[B] We want money to work the same way.
[B] Not like speculative money.
[B] But like actual US.
[A] Right.
[B] Dollars, euros.
[B] Real money.
[A] Right.
[B] You know?